- Thomas Trudel, 16 ans, qui
fréquentait l'école secondaire
Joseph-François-Perrault dans
le quartier St-Michel, a été
froidement abattu en début
de soirée tout près de son
école, le 14 novembre dernier.
Bien c'est justement pour
éviter ce genre de drame que la
Ville de Montréal et son Service
de police annoncent la création
d'une nouvelle équipe
d'intervention auprès des jeunes
d'écoles secondaires notamment.
VINCENT RICHER,
directeur adjoint SPVM
- Donc, cette équipe
mutidisciplinaire-là est
composée de criminologues,
d'un expert en médias sociaux,
d'un expert aussi en
développement des programmes
et de quatre policiers.
ALAIN VAILLANCOURT, securité
publique comité exécutif, Mtl
- Quand on peut rattraper
un jeune qui fait des petits
délits, bien ça évite beaucoup
de problèmes dans le futur.
Ça, c'est démontrer dans trer ds
les aspects de la prévention,
ça c'est un des objectifs
et aussi de venir en appui
aux parents.
- Les médias sociaux sont
un des moyens de communication
préférés des jeunes, mais
ils peuvent être aussi un moyen
de proférer des menaces
par exemple.
VALÉRIE BIRON, dir. comm.,
Centre services Pointe-de-l'Île
- Cette équipe-là va pouvoir
nous permettre d'ajouter
par exemple, au niveau
de la cylité, qui est
un enjeu pour lequel on n'a pas
toujours dans les écoles,
l'expertise requise.
Cette équipe-là va nous apporter
ce soutien supplémentaire-là
pour agir à plusieurs niveaux.
- Quand on parle de violence
dans les écoles et de violence
en général, selon ce spécialiste
en sécurité publique, et bien
on parle d'un problème qui
ne peut pas être règlé seulement
par les l'ordre.
JONAS RUTLAND,
prof. Université Concordia
- Je pense qu'on mise encore
une foisune foisune foisune foie
pour règler un problème social.
- Cette nouvelle équipe-école
sera mise en place au cours
des procaines.
Maintenant, la Ville de Montréal
et sans doute la population
en général, espèrent qu'elle
freiner et surtout
prévenir la violence
dans la ville.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-C Radio-C Radio-C Radio-n